Have you had a chance to read the article on the Randall Cycle and Cortisol that I emailed you?
If so, wondering if you agree or disagree with Mercola's change of mind regarding long-term, low-carb diets and digestive eating?
Since I've experienced recent minor weight gain that seems to be explained by my high-fat intake while failing to lower-carb intake enough,
I've inclined to correct course by reverting back to my initial higher-carb lower-fat approach.
So I did get to read Dr. Mercola's article and watch his video, and that's what he's advocating is that some people need to go back to a higher-carb low-fat approach.
But I'll tell you my opinion about it in a second.
I also want to enhance my body's production of N80 plus by taking his recommended 50mg dose of diacinamide three times per day.
I'm curious on how this might interplay with my high-holeocystine levels that I manage by supplementing with B.
I currently take premier research, complete B, serving sizes, two caps, I'm taking three,
and here's the dosage of what's on there since I'm getting 37.5 mg diacinamide here, maybe I only need two doses of the 50 mg.
So what do I think about his approach?
So honest opinion, I think that changing one's diet.
So everything you got to understand, everything he said in that information is not pertain to cancer patients.
You got to remember literally everything you read, you have to read through the lens of what it does for a cancer patient
versus what it does for a non-cancer patient.
So that being said, his approach, what he was recommending is that he tends to be fairly dogmatic.
It is approach that he's switching back to a high-carb low-fat diet.
And he recommends simple carbs, not complex carbs.
Now, I see that that can be good for some people at different times.
I think rotating your diet can be helpful, so in that sense, I would agree with him.
But to advocate a high-carb low-fat diet for people, I think can be extremely dangerous.
First of all, I think the worst diets that were ever created and caused more ill health,
long-term, not only to the person, but to the children of these people, especially if it was a female,
because this type of diet was really prominent in the 60s and 70s.
And even into the 80s was a low-fat diet.
And all these products came out that were low-fat, low-fat.
You still see them on the shelf, these low-fat products.
I think that is the most detrimental.
All your cell membranes are phospholipid bilayers, meaning they are made from fats.
Your brain cells are made from fats.
And we saw horrible detrimental effects to low-fat diets back in the 80s,
when I was practicing back then in the 80s.
It was actually in the 90s, too.
And what little child who was two years old still could not even sit up at two years old.
And that is actually the name de syndrome called floppy baby syndrome.
Yes, that was the name of it.
Floppy baby syndrome.
And it was caused from what, not enough fat of the diet.
The mother was on a low-fat diet all the way through the pregnancy.
And if she was breastfeeding on a low-fat diet, she kept her child on a low-fat diet once they were eating food.
I remember having this baby who couldn't sit up was floppy down.
All we did is start that baby on a liquid omega-3.
And within two weeks, they were sitting up.
And within several months, they were standing up against the table and they were walking around the table.
In saying how bad it is to go on a low-fat diet.
So for him to come up with that, it was just really strange watching him understand that.
But I do understand that I just wish he would have said this a few more times that
this could be, this should be, if you're going to do this, it should be short-term.
And it's not for everybody.
And then he was advocating simple carbohydrates.
And he gave some reasons for simple carbohydrate use.
All these things that he said were, would be, in my mind, dangerous to a cancer patient.
Simple carbohydrate use, you got glucose.
The cancer patient is burning glucose through glycolysis.
You're kicking out two ATPs.
And if you have plenty of simple carbohydrates to burn,
the cancer patient will actually, that cancer cell will even be further trained to feed
mainly off of glycolysis and the low oxidative form and feed it off of lactate.
So I think that would be a very dangerous approach for cancer.
Furthermore, he went on to talk about NAD and the importance of NAD and stimulating NAD,
NAD plus NADH through using niacinamide.
Now, I think a healthy dose of niacinamide, which you're going to find in your B vitamins,
is going to be just fine.
But when you're increasing NAD, it has multiple problems.
So NAD increases the recycling of glutathione and for a non-cancer patient, that's great
because we are experiencing way too much oxidative stress.
Remember, poisons, oxidizing agents, reactive oxygen species,
can damage cells, can damage cell membranes, can damage nucleus of cell, and can cause cancer,
cause mitochondrial damage, et cetera, et cetera. That can cause cancer, but a person with cancer,
a cancer cell because it's in rapid replication does not have perfectly formed mitochondria.
Therefore, it does not produce adequate amounts of glutathione because it's in rapid replication.
And therefore, it's more susceptible to reactive oxygen species, aka oxidizing agents,
and will be killed by oxidizing agents. And it's not always a good idea to stimulate
the decreasing amount to stimulate the death of, or the oxidation, the death of reactive oxygen
species in a cancer patient. That's why, question, a couple weeks ago, should all cancer patients
beyond glutathione, the answer is no, they shouldn't be on glutathione, or should they be on things
that are going to stimulate that, that every cancer patient should because reactive oxygen species
can kill cancer patients, cancer cells. So you can actually keep a cancer alive by doing that.
So you have to be careful with that. I don't say you, this whoever asked this question,
shouldn't be on that. I'm not saying that every cancer patient should limit NAD, NADH,
glutathione, glutathione precursors, I'm not saying they should, but I'm just saying that you can't take
a piece of information that will be good for the general public and automatically apply it to someone
who has a history of cancer or has active cancer. Because many times what is good for, especially when
you talk about what's good for somebody with, with coronary disease, the opposite is true for cancer.
Things that will stimulate nitric oxide and nitric oxide synthase for coronary patient
shouldn't be used with the cancer patient because it's going to stimulate endothelial growth factor.
And so you just got to be careful equating those two. I don't say it's necessarily bad,
I'm just saying that you just have to be careful equating it. And as far as diet goes,
you certainly don't want to be feeding your cancer. As a cancer patient, I would be far less
concerned with increasing, oh, I've gained 10 pounds and I don't feel as healthy,
than I would by having my cancer start growth. So, you know, somebody asked a question a few
months ago, I'm 10 pounds, how about 10 pounds overweight? What could I do to get rid of this weight?
Honestly, as a cancer patient, that would be my least concern as having me in a little bit
overweight. My most concern is how do I keep this cancer from stopped growing? So,
you don't want to be doing things that could potentially be the cancer and could potentially
negate effects of cancer-killing properties in your body. So, back to the NADH,
glutathione issue, any chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent, any chemotherapy is doing exactly
the opposite of what Dr. McColo was represented in this video. So, certainly, if your person is on
chemotherapy, you don't want to be doing this approach for sure. So, long-winded approach,
I think I have a bunch of creation on the website about this too.